si han sido 93 votos a favor de expulsar
a rusia del consejo de derechos humanos
24 en contra y 58 abstenciones entre los
votos en contra encontramos a países
como venezuela bolivia china irán y
nicaragua y en los votos y en las
abstenciones están países como emiratos
árabes o mexico antes de comenzar esta
votación rusia había advertido que
cualquier país que mantenga una
abstención que vote oa abstenerse será
considerada como no amistosa y que eso
tendrá consecuencias
bilaterales hemos escuchado también al
representante de ucrania que antes de
comenzar esta sesión ha dicho que las
imágenes que hemos visto de butch han
dejado claro lo lejos que ha llegado
rusia esta resolución fue presentada por
eeuu y es una muestra de las graves
preocupaciones que hay del conflicto y
de esas imágenes que estamos viendo
llegar de fallecidos y de víctimas de
ucrania va a ser la primera vez en la
historia que se expulse a un miembro
permanente del consejo de seguridad del
consejo de derecho humanos nunca antes
había ocurrido y la segunda vez que se
expulsa a un país del consejo de
derechos humanos antes se había
expulsado a libia en el 2011 hemos visto
que algunos países como china venezuela
decían que hasta que no haya una
investigación
esto no puede esta votación no debería
seguir adelante pero aún así ha seguido
adelante y ha salido positiva ha salido
a favor de que se expulse a rusia de
este consejo de derechos humanos porque
ha contado con dos tercios de los síes
que era lo que se necesitaba para que
esta resolución saliera adelante